okay
this is the thing um we've done a lot of
work on
on ionic uh bonds and i drew the ionic
bond energy again
on monday and remember you know in an
ionic bond like so let's take sodium
chloride
right we have oh we're gonna go lewis
right
well people say well why'd i draw that
dot there i could have drawn two dots
there and that dot there just
sure yeah but they're kind of looking at
each other so
you know and and remember in an ionic
bond
chlorine is like give me i want
and that's the kind of relationship they
have right and so
this went into something like this where
sodium was like okay fine
uh take it i'm a plus now and chlorine
was like thank you very much
i'm fully octeted
right like that and that's the ionic
bond so this is ionic
and we've learned this okay but see
there's another kind of bond that can
happen it's not
all about taking and and one per
it can also be about sharing about
sharing
and and it's you know and so if i have
hydrogen instead let's suppose i have
high
like up there and i've got hydrogen now
and here's hydrogen well see when they
gaze in tight when they see
each other a very different thing
happens
because one of the hydrogens doesn't say
gimme
and the other one doesn't say sure oh
but something else happens
right because they get they get kind of
closer
they get closer and closer oh
let's let's look at this in terms of
like okay so here's a plus
and a minus oh yeah it's
not an orbit it's an orbital and here's
another plus
and here's another minus and these
electrons you know the thing is the
electrons are like i don't like you
other electron you're repelling me and
the protons are like i don't like you
other proton
you're repelling me but the electrons do
like protons and at a certain point
if you bring these together the election
you know one of them is like well hey i
got an idea
what if i'm attracted to you sometimes
over here and i'm this electron i'm like
i kind of
i want to be attracted to you and i'll
tell you what you can be attracted to my
proton
and we'll share we'll share and
everybody
and so when when these come together
what you get is
is the protons um kind of
you know are sort of a certain distance
apart that's set by how far you can push
them in
without them feeling that repulsion and
the electrons as long
as they don't get like you know super on
top of each other because they're going
to repel each other
they're happier they're happier because
they got two positive charges that they
can kind of go around
and be near that leads to happiness
lower energy bond
but you can see right now this is a very
different kind of bond
right this is not ionic this is covalent
this is covalent when atoms
share electrons
it's a covalent bond okay and that
is something we write differently
we write it with a dash well or you
could you know you could also have
written it or maybe you you just say
well let's just put those electrons in
between them
like that right and it's showing that
those electrons didn't go to one or the
other
they're in between they are what are
making up the bond
together sharing those protons uh across
the atoms now
okay so that's nice but what hap that's
hydrogen
what happens when we get to something a
little bit more
complicated right so let's go to
water now if i have something like water
so now i'm going to go
through some examples let's suppose i
have water well i've got this here and
i've got this here and
now remember we're going to think about
things in terms of lewis dots
which i introduced you on monday those
are the valence
electrons in an atom which are what do
all of the chemical bonding
so those are the ones we're going to
care now how many dots do i have for
oxygen i forget six and if you didn't
know
you know where to look because you're
always carrying your periodic table with
you
always and so i might write six like
that
but okay what what lines do i draw
where how are these shared
so how are
the electrons shared
in bonds in covalent bonds
co-valent bonds and that
is where lewis
will help that is where lewis will help
how
do i take these valence configurations
of electrons
and make a molecule with these kinds of
sharing bonds in it
um and and there's actually there's a
very there's a fairly simple
recipe that i want to teach you today
because that's how we're going to do it
and the recipe is written here and don't
worry there's a lot of text here but i'm
going to go through it
for three different examples and if you
haven't
because in tight done louis i know some
of you have in high school some of you
have not
that's okay if you haven't practice is
really key
right we'll do three molecules maybe
four
today and i encourage you to do a bunch
more in as practice
and this is the recipe for drawing lewis
structures
and and lewis structures is what tells
us how electrons are bonded
in in in these in these molecules and so
let's
follow this for the one i have up here
let's follow this
for water okay so we're going to go
through this recipe now
the first place so one through six i
will write one through six
for the example i will parallel that
recipe so
first connect atom central atom central
atom is often the least electronegative
already i'm stuck because i didn't tell
you anything about electronegativity
that's coming a little later today i
will tell you what electronegativity is
for now trust me so the first step is
connect atoms
central atom is often the least
electronegative
um okay well so let's see so for water
so step
one um the h atoms
are going to be terminal that means that
they're on the outside
terminal okay outside also called
terminal and so the arrangement should
be
something like h o
and h okay good so that's going to be my
arrangement
okay step two determine the total number
of valence electrons okay
i can do that so two well i've got
one two three okay i've got eight
valence electrons
good okay step three is
where it gets really fun place bonding
pair
of electrons go all in just like i did
for you know so there's a bonding pair
right there
there they are two electrons in a
bonding pair
so place them okay place bonding pair
between adjacent atoms okay i can do
that so
let's see here we go um h
o h right
okay so there's my bonding pair i put
two electrons
but now you see i said okay i i only
used up
four electrons there that's okay now
starting with the now
add enough add enough electrons to each
one
to form an octet
start with terminal atoms add enough
electrons to form an
octet okay so let's see but hydrogen is
special because hydrogen's octet
is just two hydrogen doesn't want eight
hydrogen just wants two so we call it it
out here in the recipe two for hydrogen
okay so add enough electrons to form an
octet well
see each h atom already has if i look at
remember they're sharing they're sharing
okay so
each h atom already has two the the two
electrons that it wants
right and so so for four
i've got that and oh i started with the
terminal
atoms okay and so for four i've got
um each h
is okay it has
two right has two electrons which is
what it wants in its valence next one
if oh now kids if there's electrons left
over
put them on the central atom okay so i
went from the terminal in i went from
the outside and
h has two h has two that's good and
oh but how do i know if i have any left
over well i did that in step two
i had a total number of electrons now
how many have i used
i've used two here and i've used two
here
i i have four left over because i
started with eight
right and i i was just told from step
five to put those on the central atom
okay so step five now
is gonna make this look interesting so h
o h and now
i'm not going to put them in a bond
right i'm just going to put them on the
atom and those are called non-bonding
because they're well okay that's a
genius name
non-bonding because they're not bonding
that's a good name for those electrons
you can also call those lone pairs
because they're lone
they're not involved in a bond all right
so those are my four extra electrons
and then finally okay so now uh if the
cent no oh
if the central atom is less than an
octet use the lone pairs from terminal
atoms
well this looks complicated i don't want
to deal with it why because
i've got an octet here already
so six is not needed
because everything
since the oxygen since
o is happy it's got its octet
right so that is a very slow
we went slow we'll go faster now right
that is a very slow introduction to how
to do a lewis dot diagram
for a molecule in this case h2o now you
may notice i drew it
linear we know some of
some of us know that is not the shape of
this molecule but shapes come later
shapes come next week right right now
we're not
we're not thinking about shapes let's do
another example so my next example
is o
c l i'm taking this
and i'm putting a charge on it so here's
my next example ah
two might well anyway okay that's my
example i'm gonna go
through the numbers again i'm gonna go a
little faster so i wanna know
how this looks in a lewis structure
um well okay so there's only two atoms
so
um maybe i should have called this
example b so
because now i have point one right so
there's only two atoms so there's no
central
atom okay that's sounds like that might
be easy
and then uh step two is how many valence
electrons are there well there's
there's six plus seven plus one right so
there's
oxygen is six chlorine
is seven plus one equals 14
electrons where did the one come from
well that's because it's got a negative
charge here it's a negatively charged
molecule okay good now
okay now it gets interesting place
bonding pair of electrons between
adjacent atoms
so my adjacent atoms are these two atoms
which i could write like this
or i could also have written it like
this
okay okay those are equivalent
now step four okay now starting with the
terminal atoms add enough electrons to
each one to form an octet
so let's go through this so now step
four
okay step four is
so i've got okay now this
has these two elect this can count the
two electrons
this can count those two electrons you
see how this works because we're sharing
now
no one took we're sharing so they can
each count those
right because of what i drew up there in
terms of how a covalent bond works
but now but they need another six to
form an octet
that's a how many but i don't i use 2
how many do i have left
i've got 12 left is perfect
right it's perfect so i've got exactly
as many as i want
and i can write o has all of those
cl has all of these and if we want to be
careful about it we will emphasize that
this molecule is not neutral
it got an extra electron that's why we
put that minus sign up there
right it is charged and this molecule
okay each atom let's see okay i use the
extra electrons
if electrons left to no electrons left
over
if central atom is no they're they're
already octets
so 5 and 6 are not
needed oh but you know the last example
is going to be more interesting so let's
do that
last example o c
example c o so i've got h
okay i'm just going to write the atoms
here because i'm starting
well i don't even know what it's going
to look like i don't even want to hint
at it
those are my atoms i've got two
hydrogens an oxygen and a chlorine
okay i'm sorry a carbon oh yeah i meant
this to be a carbon
there we go two hydrogens an oxygen and
a carbon
okay now as we will see when i tell you
what electronegativity is carbon has the
lowest electronegativity
okay and so i'm going to put that in the
center
that's going to tell me that carbon goes
that if i answer point one it might look
something like this with these
oh and now it's taking some some form
right okay so the hydrogens are gonna go
like that they're terminal the oxygen is
outside
carbon's in the middle and how many
electrons do i okay so now
let's see answering step two um
i've got 12 valence electrons
okay because i've got you know six
four five six right six plus so 12.
okay good and now i'm going to put the
bonding pair in there so let's do that
so step three okay so now i've got c
h h o
so i've done step three and how many
okay so i've got two
four six i've used up six electrons in
the in this sharing
you know a covalent bond situation
and i started with 12 so that means i've
got
um i've got six left okay so i'm going
to go to step four
now starting with the thermal atoms add
enough to each one to form an octet now
hydrogen is good
right because hydrogen remember its
octet is double it it's two
so that's good but what about oxygen
okay it looks like oxygen needs some
so now we're going to write the
structure
like this i gotta add six more electrons
to oxygen in order to fulfill its octet
right now oxygen
is oxygen is happy
right yeah it is
just like that but look okay if
electrons are left over
are there any electrons left over no
no so i can't place electrons in the
central atom yet
now we invoke number six if central atom
is less than an octet it is
two two two then
use lone pairs from terminal atoms to
form multiple bonds to the central atom
oh yeah now we're there now we're there
so now we jump to step six
and we make because look let's let's
continue because look
if i add all these up and i go to carbon
it's not happy
but let's make it happy because that's
what lewis lets us do
and i'm going to go down to here
six continued and all i need to do
to do that is to follow the instructions
which is take
one lone pair and put it here so i'm
going to draw these explicitly now as
dots
right so i took one of those lone pairs
and i moved it here
and i created a stronger sharing
bond it's all because of you know
i wrote down the the guidelines of lewis
remember on monday and the third point
was octet
right atoms want to achieve their
nearest octet and this this
tells us then by following these steps
to implement lewis's dream and vision
we get nothing less than the nature of
bonding itself and molecules
that's cool and so and so you could you
could write this with
with sticks if you want right c h that's
a double bond
with those electrons up there that's the
same thing and now if you count
happy happy happy happy
everybody's happy caring
is sharing they're all sharing
so this is this is kind of the the
general idea of lewis lewis
the following the lewis prescription
tells us about covalent bonds
and it tells us how many electrons are
going to be shared now
it also tells us something else that's
very important and it's through this
concept called formal charge so that's
the next thing
that we need to learn see because
now i go to another molecule in this
case it's formaldehyde
okay ch2o and but look
now neither of these is done these are
not done
but it's like my starting place and it
sort of looks okay carbon central here
it's kind of central-ish there
i mean can't i start with either of
these
and and the answer is yes you can and
you can draw
and and let's do that you can actually
draw
correct lewis structures um let me use
the board over here
okay so
right so uh so i could have drawn i
could draw this like this
h uh let me see here
h c um double bond
o hydrogen and i could put that there
and that
there or i could draw it like this
so i have it this way yes right like
this
and carbon double bond o
and when i look at this and i look at
the electron count
it all works out right
i got to add my lone pairs to the oxygen
well let me forget those
it all works out the number of the total
number of valence electrons is 12
in both cases and everybody's obeying
the octet rule
right but the concept of formal charge
allows us to distinguish
between which one is likely to be more
stable
and and so what formal charge is and
i've got it written out here
okay is so formal charge non-bonding
electrons count for the given atom
bonding electrons are divided equally
and so formal charge is the total
valence
of an atom so i can take any atom here
and say what's this total valence
carbon four oxygen six right
and and then so that's the total valence
of the free atom
and then i subtract from that how many
non-bonding electrons it has
plus the bonding ones over two
right and so if i do that so let's write
that
right so if i think about that because
in tight
from my pictures
okay from my pictures
the formal charge formal charge
is equal to
the number of valence
electrons of the free atom that means
the atom before it ever
before it ever participated in a bond
minus the number of dots
minus the number of lines
because that is really the same that's
the same definition
right that's the same definition so
if so if if an so if let's go up to this
one so now if
if i look at carbon
in this configuration and i calculate
the formal charge on carbon it's going
to be
4 the valence electron of the free atom
minus 2 because it's got the two dots
there
right minus three one
two three or the total number of
electrons involved in bonds divided by
two
six over two three right
so those are equivalent but that means
that the formal charge
on this is i just
just spell it out here for now formal
charge
is equal to minus one and if i do the
same thing here then
it's plus one but you see if i look at
this structure
and i think about the formal charge on
the carbon atom again
i'm you know i'm basically counting
a change from the free atom okay
and so carbon had four um and now
it's you know what did what did this new
bonding environment
do to the valence chemistry
and in this case the formal charge on
carbon is going to be
four starting with the number of free
elect you know free valence electrons
minus no dots but it's got one two three
four bonds okay so that's zero
and the formal charge on the oxygen is
gonna be six
minus one two three four five six so
that's also zero
and you get a sense how much did i did i
push this atom
away from where it sort of normally
thinks about its charge balance
and you get a sense for why this might
be true lewis structure with the set of
formal charges closest to zero
is usually the most stable and that's
our guideline
and so this one not
very happy that one happy
right and so you can calculate the
formal charge on
on any atom in any lewis structure goes
in tight
by following this this uh this very
simple procedure
you take any atom and you look at how
you've drawn its lewis
structure right and you just count
so for example if i take co2
and i think well i can do the same thing
here i've got two lewis structures and
they're
they look like they both satisfy the
recipe
the recipe is satisfied but which one is
more stable well if i look at this
it's the same idea and
i won't go through it in detail but um
but if i look at this then you know c
o o with
lone pairs on the o's like that right
this is going to give me formal charges
of 0
0 and 0. whereas
if i do the one on the right and i put a
triple bond so i put too many electrons
sharing
then yeah i satisfied the octets
but no i'm not as stable because the
formal charges
aren't as close to zero
so this gets me to my my brief why this
matters for today so you know
you say why is why would i care which
one of these
co2 takes right okay well it turns out
that
as long as we're not at absolute zero
this molecule is moving
and and so obviously that's related to
this
it's not obvious but cars
in the u.s are now the number one
emitter of co2 they're the number one
cause
of co2 emissions um and
here's a nice little corner somewhere um
and and so this is coming out now from
the transportation sector you have the
most more of the co2 comes from that
than any other sector
why does it matter well and why does
this structure why does this lewis
structure matter well it has to do with
how it moves
because you see i showed you this before
and and i didn't complete it because we
were talking about electron transitions
and then i gave you the example of ozone
being really important
for absorbing in the uv and i showed you
the chemistry of ozone degradation with
cfcs
but you see there's look at this
absorption out here there's co2
right and so there's the sunlight above
the atmosphere here it is on earth and
you can see co2 there
and but see the the reason co2 absorbs
there
has to do with how it moves right it has
to do
with its vibrations now that's not
something
that you need to know but i wanted just
to to tell you know for like a test or
something but i wanted to tell you about
it because
it is directly related to what we just
did right
those vibrations and by the way that
first mode
that first mode is the one out here
doing all the ir absorption
right this one and you can see right
away like if this thing is
is wiggling um it's going to wiggle very
differently
right it's going to wiggle very
differently whether it has
two double bonds on either side of the
carbon or a triple in a single
right and so that alone tells you
something really important about how it
interacts
in our atmosphere with uh with thermal
with radiant heat
right with ir radiation okay
that's my why this matters now
i've been i've been talking about all
these things
in absolutes and and but you see
the world is not so absolute
and and in fact we're missing a really
important part of the
of the picture here so this is h2
right there's an ionic bond where
remember it's sort of like i'm taking
okay and then it's like a coulomb
interaction and here it's a sharing
each electron sees both of those protons
right
but there's a whole bunch of room in
between
right there's a whole bunch of room in
between and so what we need what we need
next
as we talk about you know covalent bonds
is we need a way
to think about how ionic they are
right and because there's only a certain
kind of covalent bond
that's purely covalent right
now as it's written here non-polar
covalent so let's talk about that
next okay and what we're going to do is
use this term that i alluded to in the
beginning which is point number one in
your recipe
and that is electronegativity
okay so let's get a few more i'm gonna
get it done
[Music]
almost practice makes perfect
okay
right so there is a symbol
chi that we use for
this concept of electro
negativity electro negativity
okay now this is
the tendency
of an atom
to attract
a shared
pair of electrons
to itself okay so
uh let's write in a bond right just to
be sure
right in a bond so if an electron if an
atom is in a bond the question is
how much was it able to pull those
bonding electrons to it
right and um and
you know you can already kind of think
about this
in terms of concepts that we've learned
already right like the size of an atom
how far out electrons are right the
radius of an atom
right whether there's shielding going on
right this this kind of leads you how
many protons
there are right this kind of leads you
already to being able to think about
this which
which atom is going to want a pair of
electrons
in a bond right which one is going to
want it more and how much
but it was pauling who said no i want to
go further than that i want to write
down
even if it's empirical i want to write
down some way
some number i want to quantify this
and um and so he came up with a scale
for electronegativity the term and
concept of electronegativity goes back
long before appalling to i think
brazilians but um
but pauling is the one who said i want
to quantify this and the way we're going
to do this is we're just going to
measure
bonding energies between all sorts of
different atoms
right and what he found is that you know
if if a bonds to a
and b bonds to b a to b is not just a
simple sum of the two
and that clued him in for how to think
about this
this kind of partially covalent or polar
covalent nature
i'll tell you why that word polar is
there in a few minutes
and so pauline developed this scale the
electronegativity scale to tell us this
and he arbitrarily set fluorine to four
and uh hydrogen at first 1.2 now sorry
2.1 now it's 2.2
um but but basically this is just some
of the elements of periodic table and
these are their electronegativities
okay and um and you don't need to worry
about how this scale was developed
quantitatively there are actually many
electronegativity scales what i want you
to know
is is sort of what it means conceptually
and then how to use it to think about
whether a bond is going to be
ionic or covalent or somewhere in
between
and so you can see already here okay the
extremes of this are fluorine
and cesium these are the most
electronegative
least electronegative or if you want to
to be positive about it
you know most electro positive when
you're talking to these elements
you want them to feel good they're not
the least they
are very important so they're electro
positive right
and now you know conceptually but look
now we also can think about
differences because if the difference
between this concept from one atom to
another
is zero well then that must be a pure
covalent bond
because neither one could bring in
the electron pair more than the other
right so if i think about that so like
chlorine two
right the chlorine dimer then the change
in electronegativity between one
chlorine another
is zero it's a pure covalent
i mean just think about that
conceptually right so the the
that's what electronegativity means
so if i have two atoms that are the same
neither one can draw in they have the
same
chi neither one can draw the pair
towards them more
right so the same is true for any dimer
like this where it's the same atom
right the h2 dimer that we started with
also has
delta chi of zero those are called pure
covalent
because it's just pure sharing nobody
took more charge than the other but see
if i go to
something like sodium chloride well now
i can calculate from this table i can
calculate
the difference in electronegativity
between sodium and chlorine
and it's 2.23
which is pretty high and
it's ionic and therefore this is so if
it's high
if that difference is high then it means
one of the atoms grabbed
the electrons and if it's kind of
if it's zero it's pure covalent and if
it's somewhere in between
it's this polar covalent so for example
hcl
so these are all with the same atom
chlorine but here
delta chi is equal to
0.96 so this is called
um polar covalent
okay so this is also
partially ionic right these mean the
same things
there's ionic character is another way
that we say it
this bond is not purely covalent because
one of them took a little more charge
because it's like
electronegativity was higher and
therefore
there's a little bit of that kind of
ionic thing going on because you got
like a little plus over here
in a little minus over there right
and that is something
let's see okay
um now
that is something that can be looked at
for a whole bunch of different
um bonds and so here this is what
pauline was
trying to fit so he came up with these
empirical fits
right you say okay things kind of tend
to
lie on this line um
which is the the plot of the
electronegativity difference between two
different atoms and the percent
ionic character the percent ion
is it really fully ionic is it is it
fully covalent you see
over here it's kind of not interesting
right it's just anything with itself is
zero
and over here you've got some of the
same ionic
bonds that we've already talked about
right and then you got all this stuff in
between and
and what this is is as as you've now
seen right
aufbau is a suggestion of a rule and
then it gets broken
20 of the time um this is also a way of
qualitatively classifying bonds and
thinking about
the you know the ionic character in a
bond but it is not
always quantitative but in general
what you'll see is that if delta chi
is greater than 2 then it tends to be
an ionic bond and if delta chi
is less than let's say 1.6
it tends to be covalent or
you know polar covalent polar covalent
and in between you know it it depends
missing how do i know right let's show
you an example
if i take uh where's my example an
example here
sodium bromide not on there but if i
take sodium bromide
and i take hf
they both have delta chi
equal 1.9 so the reason now some
textbooks will simply say
1.7 you will see that in some textbooks
and because they just want it to be all
or nothing it's always
ionic or but the fact of the matter is
that in this intermediate regime
you get variations that depend on other
things
and so for example you know hf is a gas
at room temperature
right so these have the same
electronegativity difference but this
really behaves like a polar covalent
molecule
and this really behaves like an ionic
solid
an ionic bond how do you know it's the
properties
right remember i showed you the
properties of ionic solids
right on on monday and so i can look at
those and check them off you know solid
room temperature et cetera
and i can see well does this fit the
bill does it look like an ionic solid
and it absolutely does not
so even though this is the same you got
to be careful in this intermediate
regime
now you can also go even further and you
can get quantitative
because you see what we're really
talking about here
is something called the dipole
that is why it's called polar covalent
okay it's called polar covalent because
we made a dipole and as far as i
uh know from my electricity and
magnetism training
the dipole moment mu is written as mu
is the charge times the distance where q
is the
the charge in this case it's literally
the charge that was pulled
it's exactly it's that there's the chart
right
tendency to pull a shared electron a
pair of
you know i pulled it over here so
i created a little more negative charge
on me
and a little positive charge on on there
and that
that meant that i've got a partial
charge now separated by a distance
right and and so you can actually use
this to get quantitative so let's do
sodium chloride
right so for sodium chloride the dipole
moment is nine to buy
and this is just you know one to buy
this is charge times distance so one to
by
is equal to 3.3
10 to the minus 30th coulomb
meters that's the units of a of a dipole
moment
charge times distance so if i take
sodium
chloride and i tell you that its dipole
moment
is nine to buy then i also have to tell
you that the distance
between them r is equal to
2.36 angstroms that is this distance
here
i've made a bond between these two
things
and that bond is some distance apart
well that's exactly the distance i need
to think about the dipole right
so remember a dipole is because i've got
positive charge
and negative charge and in fact you
might see it written like this
you might see like there's a little
positive charge here
and a little negative charge there and
the dipole moment goes
like that right there's a dipole
it's that i've got two and now those
charges at this distance in the bond
allow me to actually be quantitative
because
q is equal to mu over r
and if i plug that in then it's 1.3
times 10 to the minus 19th coulombs
so for sodium chloride because i was
given the dipole moment in that
in that molecule and i can look up the
bond distance
i can actually tell you how much charge
are on those
atoms right if i know that information
but i also know what the charge of an
electron is
of a full electron is and this is almost
there
it's something like um
see eighty percent
of an electron and so
that's a pretty strong ionic bond but
it's not a hundred percent
right and so this is the message i want
to tell you is you know in reality
we've been talking about absolutes i
fully took a charge
right no you didn't
you took 80 and there's a little bit
still over there
right and so this is a way but
we light we do like to still categorize
materials
and that's what this does really nicely
is it says well this is going to behave
like an ionic solid meaning it's going
to have those properties that i showed
you on monday
right even though it's not fully ionic
it's pretty darn ionic
right and and now even though these are
not
fully covalent meaning pure non-polar
covalent
nonpolar no dipole
in there in the bond but these have some
dipole
but that's okay they're still acting
like covalent solids or covalent
molecules
right and so there's this spectrum in
between
and you can use these concepts to think
about the bonding and to think about
you know in particular this that so many
bonds are actually like this even though
we categorize them like this and we
think about them like that
right they actually look kind of like
this and as
electronegativity and dipoles
are what help us characterize these
these differences
now um there's more to louis
um that i will talk about on friday
but um so there's there's something
called resonant structures
and that's a very important part of
louis i'm going to talk about it friday
and it will not be on
the exam on monday okay but on friday
we'll talk about
resident structures do a few more lewis
examples and then i'll talk about
exam one
you